Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest is History, and I want to start today's episode by reading an index entry from a book called Seasons in the Sun, The Battle for Britain, 1974-1979. And in the index of this book, we find Thorpe jeremy 1979 election contracts gonorrhea from greek prostitute plans to have his ex-lover eaten by florida alligators scandal trial wades ashore from sinking hovercraft and wilson and the man who compiled that index and wrote the book, Dominic Sandbrook, is, well, he's not sitting alongside me, he's in Chipping Norton and I'm in Brixton, but
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你好，欢迎收听《历史的余味》。今天我想从一本名为《阳光下的季节：1974-1979年英国之战》（Seasons in the Sun, The Battle for Britain, 1974-1979）的书的索引条目开始。在这本书的索引中，我们发现了“索普，杰里米（Thorpe, Jeremy）：1979年选举，因希腊妓女染上淋病，计划让前情人被佛罗里达短吻鳄吃掉，丑闻审判，从沉没的气垫船上蹒跚上岸”，而编写该索引并撰写此书的人，多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook），他……好吧，他并没有坐在我身边，他在奇平诺顿（Chipping Norton），而我在布里克斯顿（Brixton），但是
he's virtually sitting alongside me. The Jeremy Thorpe scandal. Now, this is a topic that lots of our British listeners will recognise because Hugh Grant and Ben Whishaw were recently in a brilliant drama series about it, a very British scandal. Those beyond Britain may not have the first idea what this is. So we've got the questions written down here. Our most common question from all non-British listeners, what was the Jeremy Thorpe scandal? Dominic, what was the Jeremy Thorpe scandal? Yeah, that's a good question. What was the Jeremy Thorpe scandal? Well, first of all, thank you so much. I love doing those indexes.
他就像坐在我身边一样。杰里米·索普丑闻。这是一个许多英国听众都会熟悉的题目，因为休·格兰特（Hugh Grant）和本·威士肖（Ben Whishaw）最近出演了一部关于此事的精彩剧集《英式丑闻》（A Very British Scandal）。英国以外的人可能根本不知道这是什么。所以我们把问题写在这里了。我们从所有非英国听众那里收到的最常见的问题是：什么是杰里米·索普丑闻？多米尼克，什么是杰里米·索普丑闻？是的，这是个好问题。什么是杰里米·索普丑闻？嗯，首先，非常感谢。我喜欢做那些索引。
I'm glad you read that out. And we should say, shouldn't we, Tom, this isn't our idea for the podcast. This is sent in by a listener, wasn't it? By Paul Keeley. By Paul Keeley. So, Paul, this one is for you. And if nobody listens, it's all your fault.
很高兴你把它读了出来。汤姆，我们应该说，这并不是我们想出的播客点子，对吧？这是听众保罗·基利（Paul Keeley）寄来的，不是吗？是保罗·基利。所以，保罗，这一期是给你的。如果没人听，那都是你的错。
So what was the jeremy thorpe scandal well that's basically what the podcast is about so i won't give all the details away but to cut a very long story short jeremy thorpe was the leader of the liberal party in the 1970s so the liberal party was as a regular listeners of the podcast will know it was one of the great the two great parties of of sort of british democracy in the 19th century but in the 20th century it had a pretty tough time and it declined. But under Thorpe, it seemed to be making a bit of a comeback.
那么什么是杰里米·索普丑闻呢？嗯，这基本上就是本期播客的主题，所以我不会透露所有细节。长话短说，杰里米·索普是20世纪70年代自由党（Liberal Party）的领袖。正如本播客的常客所知，自由党曾是19世纪英国民主政治的两大政党之一，但在20世纪，它经历了一段相当艰难的时期并走向衰落。但在索普的领导下，它似乎有了一点复苏的迹象。
So the Liberals won almost 20% of the vote in February. This is the 70s? Yeah, in February 1974. And so, you know, you might say... That's the election where he was going around in a hovercraft? No, it was in the next election in October 1974. We'll come back to the hovercraft. So Jeremy Thorpe is the leader
自由党在2月获得了近20%的选票。这是70年代吗？是的，在1974年2月。所以，你知道，你可能会说……那是他坐着气垫船到处跑的那次选举吗？不，那是1974年10月的下一次选举。我们稍后再谈气垫船。所以杰里米·索普是
of the Liberal Party. And as implausible as it may seem, his great sort of, you know, his ride to the top of British politics is interrupted by the fact that he's accused of conspiring to murder his former lover, a stable hand and sometime model
自由党的领袖。尽管听起来难以置信，但他登上英国政坛顶峰的道路却因他被指控密谋谋杀他的前情人——一名马夫兼业余模特——而中断了，
called Norman Scott. And at first people think this story is completely mad. But then when they start looking into it, they see there's a bit more to it than that. And as the story unfolds, it brings in all these sort of bizarre characters. So you've got a fruit machine dealer, you've got a carpet salesman. There's a plot, as you alluded to, to murder this man in Florida and feed him to alligators. It sort of starts to suck in the Labour government. The newspapers run it day after day after day. And it becomes this colossal kind of core celebrity in the 70s Britain. A lot of questions are, why did it matter? I think one answer to that is it seemed to reflect a general sort of comic seederness about British politics
那个人叫诺曼·斯科特（Norman Scott）。起初人们认为这个故事完全是疯了。但当他们开始调查时，发现事情远不止于此。随着故事的展开，它引入了各种各样古怪的角色。比如一个水果机经销商，一个地毯推销员。正如你提到的，还有一个在佛罗里达谋杀此人并将其喂给短吻鳄的阴谋。它开始把工党政府也卷了进来。报纸日复一日地报道。它成为了70年代英国一种巨大的核心名人丑闻。很多人问，这为什么重要？我认为一个答案是，它似乎反映了70年代英国政治中一种普遍的滑稽的卑劣感，
in the 70s and a sense of breakdown and so on. And actually, it happens at the same time as Watergate or a year or two after Watergate, but it's a much more amusing story than Watergate. And also, it is quite a tragic story, as you'll discover when we sort of go through it there's lots of sort of broken lives involved amid all the sort of you know the sort of carnivalesque sort of bawdy farce so i mean basically we so in the past we've done we've just done adolf hitler yeah muhammad done the origins yeah we've done the origins of
以及一种崩溃感等等。实际上，它发生的时间与水门事件同时，或者在水门事件后一两年，但它比水门事件有趣得多。而且，正如你稍后会发现的，这是一个相当悲剧的故事，在那种狂欢节般的粗俗闹剧中，涉及了许多破碎的人生。所以，我的意思是，过去我们做过阿道夫·希特勒，是的，做过穆罕默德的起源，是的，做过法国大革命，那些宏大的主题。而在这里，我们非常近距离地接触了一个非英国听众甚至许多英国听众可能从未听说过的主题，然而这绝对是一个精彩的故事。正如你所说，它确实揭示了关于1970年代英国的各种事情，而且因为它涉及一段同性恋情。这是在60年代同性恋被定罪（当时杰里米·索普是一位前途无量的年轻议员，并不担心它被定罪）与我们现在同性恋被完全接受的中间点。所以，这也是对那种变化过程的一个有趣的温度测量，
islam we've done the french revolution vast sweeping themes here we're going up really up close to a subject that non-british listeners and even many british listeners will have never even heard of it and yet it is an absolutely brilliant story and as you say it it does kind of reveal all kinds of things about 1970s brit, but also because it's about a gay affair. And this is kind of midpoint between homosexuality having been criminalised in the 60s when Jeremy Thorpe is an up and coming young MP and is not worried about it being criminal. I mean, he seems to have enjoyed it. He seems to have enjoyed the whiff of danger. And of course, where we are now, where homosexuality is completely accepted so it's also a kind of interesting temperature take on the course of that that
所以我觉得从各方面来看，它都值得做一期节目。嗯，我想我们应该从杰里米·索普本人开始。我们有一个来自斯蒂芬·克拉克（Stephen Clark）的问题，他总是给我们发很棒的问题。关于杰里米·索普：一位保守党议员的儿子，老伊顿公学毕业生，三一学院的人，痴迷于娶玛格丽特公主。杰里米·索普是怎么成为自由党领袖的？因为他本来应该是个保守党人，不是吗？嗯，他来自一个保守党家庭，这实际上是一个关于自由主义的非常有趣的故事。自由主义曾是19世纪大部分时间里英国的执政信条，
change as well so i think in all kinds of ways it it well merits an episode um and i guess we should begin with jeremy thorpe himself so we have a question from stephen clark um he's always sending us great questions and it says about Jeremy Thorpe the son of a conservative MP an old Etonian a Trinity College man possessing an obsession with marrying Princess Margaret how did Jeremy Thorpe end up as leader of the Liberal Party because he should probably have been a Tory shouldn't he? Well he came from a Tory family and this is actually a really interesting story about liberalism so liberalism had been the sort of governing creed of Britain for much of the 19th century,
也是英国带入第一次世界大战的信条。然后，自由主义真的失宠了。没有雄心勃勃的政治家会加入自由党。我的意思是，你会加入工党或保守党。但自由党在英国以某种方式存活了下来。我的意思是，这是20世纪英国政治中有趣的故事之一，我们现在有了自由民主党，
and was the creed that Britain took into the First World War. And then liberalism really falls from grace. And no ambitious politician will join the Liberal Party. I mean, you'll join the Labour Party or the Tories. But the Liberal Party kind of lives on in Britain. I mean, that's one of the interesting stories about British politics in the 20th century, that we now have a Liberal Democrat Party
而自由主义传统从未消失。它以你所说的——我不是在冒犯——那种边缘形式存活了下来，即地理上的边缘。比如北威尔士、苏格兰，特别是西南部，在康沃尔和德文郡。这些地方有着深厚的卫理公会传统。
and the liberal tradition never disappeared. And it sort of survived on what you call, I'm not being rude, but there's kind of fringes, the geographical fringes. So North Wales, Scotland, and particularly in the Southwest, in Cornwall and Devon. And these are places with a big kind of Methodist tradition.
所以它们是某种持不同政见的地方。它们离伦敦很远。而且是严肃的地方。是的，没错。如果你是一个认真的人，那里没有真正的大型工会运动。所以如果你是一个自我提升的、
So they're sort of dissenting kind of places. They're a long way from London. And serious places. Yeah, exactly. If you're an earnest person, there's no real big trade union movement there. So you don't join the Labour Party if you're a sort of self-improving,
某种工人阶级自学者，或者是一个去教堂并真正认真对待它的人，你就会加入自由党。而且你还会穿凉鞋配袜子，这是刻板印象。嗯，这就是刻板印象，即你非常善意，并且非常关心外国穷人的困境等等。现在，杰里米·索普是一个彻头彻尾的流氓。
sort of working class autodidact or something, or somebody who goes to chapel and really takes it seriously, you join the Liberal Party. And you wear socks with sandals as a stereotype. Well, that is the stereotype, that you're kind of very well-meaning and you think a lot about the plight of the poor in foreign lands and that sort of thing. Now, Jeremy Thorpe is this consummate bounder.
我的意思是，他是流氓中的流氓。你知道，他在伊顿公学时，他的一大爱好是拉小提琴。然后他去了牛津，投身于牛津的政治世界。他成为了牛津法律协会主席，成为了牛津联盟主席，这是一种经典的跳板，
I mean, he is the bounder's bounder. You know, he's... At Eton, his one big thing was he played the violin. Then he goes to Oxford and he throws himself into the world of Oxford politics. He becomes president of the Oxford Law Society, becomes president of the Oxford Union, which is a sort of classic staging pose
为雄心勃勃的政治家准备的。但他没有加入保守党，这本是你所期望的。他被吸引了。我甚至怀疑在那个阶段，索普就非常浮夸，而且他显然是同性恋。我想他知道自己是同性恋。
for ambitious politicians. But he doesn't get involved with the Tory party, which you would expect. He's drawn. And I wonder whether even at this stage, there's this sort of, Thorpe is incredibly flamboyant and he's clearly gay. He knows he's gay, I think.
所以有一个问题，嗯，甚至不是一个问题，是卢·斯莫雷尔斯（Lou Smorrells）的评论：关于杰里米·索普，我唯一记得的就是他糟糕的帽子品味。是的，所以当其他人都不再戴帽子时，他还在戴。他在帽子被视为一种古怪标志的时候戴帽子。是的。我想他加入自由党是因为，
So there's a question from, well, it's not even a question, it's a comment from Lou Smorrells. All I remember about Jeremy Thorpe was his bad taste in hats. Yeah, so he wears a hat after everybody else no longer wears a hat. He wears a hat at a point where a hat is a sort of mark of eccentricity. Yeah. And I think he went into the Liberal Party because,
如果你非常有才华，他非常风趣，非常聪明，他是一名大律师。出色的模仿者。他是一个出色的模仿者，没错。所以如果你能做所有这些事情，你知道，在保守党里这种人多如牛毛，那种时髦的流氓类型。而如果你加入自由党，那里基本上非常沉闷和低调，你知道，你可以成为自由党的领袖，你可以把它变成你个人的工具。我认为索普有一种认识，你知道，
if you were very talented, he's very funny, he's very clever, he's a barrister. Brilliant mimic. He's a brilliant mimic, exactly. so if you can do all those things you know there are they're ten a penny in the tory party sort of posh bounder types whereas if you go into the liberal party where basically it's incredibly stayed and downbeat you know you can be leader of the liberal party you can become your personal vehicle and i think there's an element of Thorpe knowing that, you know,
这几乎是一条轻松的道路。他可以去加入。我的意思是，话虽如此，汤姆，在我们把索普塑造成这个滑稽人物之前，他也是一个真正的自由主义者。他非常敌视种族隔离，不是吗？所以他是南非种族隔离政权的坚定反对者。是的，没错。
it's almost an easy ride. He can go and join. I mean, all of that said, Tom, before we set Thorpe up as this comic figure, he's also genuinely liberal. And he's very hostile to apartheid, isn't he? So he's a committed opponent of the apartheid regime in South Africa. Yes, exactly.
实际上，这将贯穿整个故事，即南非的联系。所以这是他在50年代进入英国政坛，从那时起，你知道，嗯，非常反种族主义，非常反种族隔离，在这些问题上非常进步，确实让他在政治上脱颖而出。因为这在……我的意思是，工党里有人，也有一些保守党人。而且当这与喜欢戴帽子的嗜好结合在一起时，尤其不寻常。如果你很浮夸，那就不是这样。这是奇怪的事情。在英国政治中，浮夸通常意味着你非常右翼。索普不是那样的人。
And actually that's going to run through this through this whole story the south african connection so this is he enters british politics in the 50s really and from that point onwards you know um being very anti-racist being very anti-apartheid being very kind of progressive on these kinds of issues really marks you out in politics it's Because it's not really that usual in... I mean, there are people in the Labour Party and there are some tourists. And especially not when combined with a penchant for wearing hats. Not if you're flamboyant. That's the weird thing. Being flamboyant in British politics often means you're very right-wing. Thorpe is not like that.
他绝对致力于人权和这些问题，这让他从那些穿凉鞋配袜子的人那里得到了大大的赞赏。但他很风趣。他非常风趣。这是一个问题。所以他致力于人权。他是反种族主义者。他也致力于同性恋权利吗？所以他的同性恋身份，他是同性恋，但在一个同性恋非法的时代，他却浮夸地表现出来。所以他不断地在危险的边缘徘徊。这纯粹是个人的事情，还是他在通过这样做来表达某种政治观点？不，他根本没有表达任何政治观点。对。
He's absolutely committed to human rights and to these kinds of issues that get him big ticks from the sort of socks and sandals people. But he's funny. He's very funny. Here's a question. So he's committed to human rights. He's anti-racist. Was he also committed to gay rights? And so is his homosexuality, he's gay, but he's flamboyantly gay at a time where it's illegal. So he's constantly skirting the edge of danger. Is that a purely personal thing or is he making a political point by doing that? No, he's not making political points at all. Right.
所以他，汤姆，我想，我真的不想最终向你讲授关于世纪中叶英国的历史。如果我讲得太多，就让我闭嘴。不，不，他们在这方面做得更好，你的叙述太精彩了。所以索普，你知道，他是50年代进入政坛的一颗年轻流星，然后是60年代，在一个
So he, Tom, I think is really, I don't want to just end up lecturing you about sort of mid-century Britain. So tell me to shut up if I get too much. No, no, they were better on this and your account of it is so brilliant. So Thorpe's you know, he's a young meteor entering politics in the 50s and then the 60s, at a time
人们生活在恐惧中，对被曝光为同性恋感到极度恐惧的时代。所以曾有一个案例，上议院最年轻的成员，蒙塔古·德·比尤利勋爵（Lord Montague of Beaulieu），被送进了监狱。他因为……被关进了监狱。
when people live in terror in utter terror of being exposed as gay so there had been a case, the youngest member of the House of Lords, Lord Montague of Bewley, had been sent to prison. He'd been jailed for,
我不记得是因为什么了，是不是在公共厕所里胡搞之类的。但这在50年代是典型的事件。你会去寻找“行动”，正如他们所说。然后结果发现你搭讪的那个人实际上是一个卧底警察。你立刻被抓，被带上法庭，并在报纸上曝光。
I can't remember what it was, whether it was carrying on in public toilets or something. But this was the classic thing that happened in the 50s. You'd go to look for action, as it were. And then it turns out that the guy you've picked up is actually an undercover policeman. And you're busted and you're taken to court, you know, straight away and exposed in the newspapers.
砰，你的职业生涯就结束了。但你的妻子支持你，然后……是的。……几年后向你报告。这是经典的模式。现在，索普，作为一个年轻人，显然有这种对“粗糙交易”的嗜好，你知道，有很多在酒吧里搭讪人，以及关于在厕所或
And bang, your career is over. But your wife stands by you and then... Yeah. ...reports to you a couple of years later. That's the classic pattern. Now, Thorpe, as a young man, clearly had this taste for kind of rough trade you know there's a lot of kind of picking people up in pubs and stories about picking people up in toilets or
街角搭讪人，把他们带回自己的房间，然后在早上给他们三英镑，然后他们就走了的故事。他确实做了很多这样的事，去国外，所以他去了希腊，在那里他染上了淋病。他向他的一些朋友嘟囔过这件事，或者向他的知己暗示过。但总的来说，你会把这种事情保密。如果曝光，它会毁了你，因为同性恋直到1960年代末才会被除罪化。对，所以杰里米·索普是什么时候遇到诺曼·斯科特的？这个马夫是谁？嗯，情绪受损，我想说这是公平的，嗯，不是最平衡的男孩。索普是在同性恋合法化之后遇到他的，还是……？不，不，仍然是非法的。所以这很早。所以谋杀——我们将要谈到的谋杀未遂——直到70年代中期才发生，但他们是在1961年，我想是1961年初认识的。哦天哪，那么早，我没意识到。这非常早。他们实际上是在离我现在住的地方不远的金汉马厩（Kingham Stables），靠近奇平诺顿认识的，所以离我所在这个美丽的巧克力盒般的村庄只有大约三分钟的车程。他们在那里见面。我想索普是去参加一个家庭聚会之类的。
street corners and taking them back to his kind of rooms and then in the morning he'll give them three pounds and off they go and he does he does a lot of it going abroad so he goes off to greece which is where he gets his gonorrhea. And he mutters about it to some of his friends, or he hints at it to his confidence. But by and large, you keep this kind of thing very quiet. If it comes out, it will destroy you, because homosexuality is not then going to be decriminalized until the very end of the 1960s right so so when does jeremy thought meet norman scott who is this stable hand um emotionally damaged i think it would be fair to say um not not the most balanced of boys does does thought meet him once homosexuality is
然后他遇到了这个正在做马夫的人。在那时，那个人叫诺曼·约瑟夫（Norman Joseph）。他不叫诺曼·斯科特。他改名的事实让你感觉到他生活中的轻微混乱。而且，正如你所说，他是一个受损的、某种程度上不安的人，他有抱负，除其他外，想成为一名男模特。
is legal or still no no it's still illegal so it's quite early so the the the murder so the attempted murder which will come to doesn't happen till the mid-70s but they meet in 1961 i think the beginning of 1961 oh goodness that early i hadn't realized it's very early they meet actually just down the road from where i am now at kingham stables near chipping norton so it's literally about sort of three minutes drive from where i am in this beautiful chocolate boxy kind of village. They meet there. Thorpe has gone, I think, for a house party or something like that.
他遇到了索普。索普显然看上了他，并说，你知道，保持联系。他们确实保持了联系。发生的事情是，这个人最终被马厩解雇了，我想，或者在阴影下离开了，他丢失了他的国民保险号码。这是……现在，我们有几个问题，我最喜欢的问题，可能是我听过的最喜欢的问题，
And he meets this guy who's working as a stable hand. Now, at that point, the guy is called Norman Joseph. He's not called Norman Scott. The fact that he changes his name gives you some sense of the kind of slight chaos of his life. And he's, as you say, he's a sort of a damaged, kind of disturbed guy who has an ambition to, among other things, to become a male model.
克劳福特（Crowfoot），你能帮我弄一张新的国民保险卡吗？所以你能帮我……是的，这就是诺曼·斯科特一直在问杰里米·索普的问题：你能帮我弄一张新的国民保险卡吗？所以你能帮我……是的，这就是诺曼·斯科特一直在问杰里米·索普的问题：你能帮我弄一张新的国民保险卡吗？是的，这悬在这个故事的整个过程中。嗯，对于海外听众来说，他们对这一点完全感到困惑。你的国民保险卡基本上上面有一个号码，你需要它来找工作，你有这张卡，如果你记不住你的号码，或者我假设你……老实说，这不是我完全理解其机制的东西。但你基本上需要出示它才能找到工作，这样他们就可以注册，并且他们会缴纳正确的税款等等。
He meets Thorpe. Thorpe obviously takes a fancy to him and says, you know, keep in touch. And they do keep in touch. And what happens is this guy ends up getting fired, I think, from the stables or leaving under under a cloud and he's he he loses his national insurance number this is now this is we had a couple of questions my favorite question probably my favorite question we've ever had
所以他在阴影下离开了那个马厩，他没有他的卡。他变得痴迷于索普可以帮他弄一张新的国民保险卡的想法，因为索普是一名议员。所以他是一个大人物。无论如何，索普带他回家。索普，他们最终见面了。索普带他去了他母亲的家，他的母亲厄休拉（Ursula），索普与她有着非常亲密的关系。据称，那就是索普第一次某种程度上“破了他的处”的时候。
crowfoot can you get me a new national insurance card so can you get me yeah so this is the question that that norman scott is always asking jeremy thorpe can you get me a new national insurance card so can you get yeah so this is the question that that norman scott is always asking jeremy thorpe can you get me a new national insurance yes this hangs over this whole story um and for foreign for overseas listeners are utterly bewildered by this your national insurance card basically had a number on it that you needed to get a job and you had this card and if you couldn't remember your number or i assume you i mean to be honest it's not something that i fully understand the mechanics of. But you basically need to show it to get a job so they could be registered and that they would pay the right tax and all the rest of it.
任何看过这部剧的戏剧化改编的人，最近的那一部，都会记得休·格兰特说“兔子”（bunny）的那种宏伟方式。是的，是的。我无法充分向休·格兰特说“兔子”的方式致敬。我很想模仿，但我不想成为一个表情包。不。所以兔子必须去法国，而且一定会去法国？
So he's left this stable under a cloud and he hasn't got his card. And he becomes obsessed with the idea that Thorpe can get him a new national, because Thorpe is an MP. So he's a big person. Anyway, Thorpe takes get him a new national, because Thorpe is an MP. So he's a big person. Anyway, Thorpe takes him home. Thorpe, they end up meeting. Thorpe takes him to his mother's house, his mother Ursula, who Thorpe has this very close relationship with. And allegedly, that's when Thorpe first kind of deflowers him.
是的。所以，发生的事情是，他们显然见过几次面，索普对斯科特——或者约瑟夫，正如他当时自称的那样——做出了一系列承诺。抱歉，他还没自称斯科特。他给了他少量的钱，让他留下来，等等。而且
And anyone who has seen the dramatisation of this, the recent one, will remember the magnificent way in which Hugh Grant says bunny. Yeah, yes. I can't adequately do homage to the way that Hugh Grant says bunny. I'm tempted to do it, but I don't want to become a meme. No. So bunnies must and will go to France?
约瑟夫，也就是斯科特，有去巴黎的抱负，我想是这样，并成为一名模特。是的，索普某种程度上说，哦，我们可以做到，或者类似的话，但……但某种程度上并不是真的那样想，基本上对他感到厌倦了，在某个时候写了一张便条，上面写着“兔子可以去法国，而且会去法国”，或者类似的话。顺便说一句，那完全是错误的语调。是的，你听起来像丘吉尔。我无法想象丘吉尔会那样说。嗯，丘吉尔可能会说
Yeah. So, what happens is, they obviously see each other a few times, and Thorpe makes a series of promises to Scott, to Joseph, as he's calling himself. Sorry, he's not calling himself Scott yet. And he gives him small amounts of money, he lets him stay, and so on. And
这让他为身为英国人感到自豪之类的，不是吗？无论如何，他写了这张便条，而约瑟夫，也就是斯科特，保留了它，这简直是灾难性的。他保留了索普给他的所有东西。而且他保留了一封信，信中索普说他想娶玛格丽特公主之类的。
Joseph, stroke Scott, has an ambition to go to paris i think it is and become a model yes and thorpe sort of says oh we can do that or something but but it kind of doesn't really mean it and and basically tires of him and at some point writes him a note where he says bunnies can and will go to france or whatever he says that's completely the wrong voice by by the way. Yes, you sound like Churchill. I can't imagine Churchill saying that. Well, Churchill would probably say
我没弄错吧？所以索普人脉很广。所以这一切变得越来越老了。索普人脉很广。在1960年代初的某个时候，索普的朋友安东尼·阿姆斯特朗-琼斯（Anthony Armstrong Jones）娶了玛格丽特公主。所以索普与这些社会名流联系非常紧密。索普对此感到非常沮丧。
it made him proud to be British or something like that, wouldn't he? Anyway, he writes this note, and Joseph Strokescott keeps it, which is disastrous. He's keeping everything that Thorpe is giving him. And he's kept a letter in which Thorpe says that he wants to marry Princess Margaret or something.
他说，你知道，坦率地说，我想娶一个，和另一个睡觉，或者类似的话。当然，你知道，那是个玩笑，但在同性恋非法的社会背景下，那对一个有抱负的政治家来说不是什么好事。尤其不是在一封你潜在的勒索者、非常受损的前情人所持有的信中。所以时间流逝，索普基本上崩溃了。他甩掉了这个人。
Have I got that right? So Thorpe is very well connected. So it's all getting older and older. Thorpe is very well connected. And at one point, at the beginning of the 1960s, Thorpe's friend, Anthony Armstrong Jones, marries Princess Margaret. So Thorpe is very connected with these society people. And Thorpe is gutted by this.
我的意思是，对索普来说，这个人，我想，什么都不是。在电视剧中，该剧的编剧拉塞尔·T·戴维斯（Russell T. Davies）创造了一种非常悲剧和某种感觉，即这是一种受挫或注定的浪漫，有什么东西可能比它本身更宏大。但我认为在现实中，索普并没有真正把诺曼·约瑟夫或后来的斯科特当回事。他只是他搭讪并甩掉的众多年轻人中的一个过客。但对诺曼来说，这在他脑海中越来越大。他认为杰里米·索普背叛了他。而且至关重要的是，杰里米·索普偷走了他的国民保险卡。
And he says, you know, to be quite frank, I wanted to marry one and sleep with the other or something. And of course, you know, that's a joke, but it's kind of in the context of a society in which homosexuality is illegal. That's not a great thing for an aspiring politician to write. And especially not in a letter that your potentially blackmailing, very damaged ex-lover has. So time ticks by and Thorpe basically is broken. He's ditched this guy.
好的，所以我们回到那个问题。是的，所以国民保险，你感觉到这个约瑟夫家伙有多么轻微的不安。国民保险卡，我的意思是，人们在60年代的英国一定一直在丢失他们的国民保险卡。你知道，我的意思是，政府一定被人们淹没了，他们说，我丢了我的国民保险卡，我能弄一张新的吗？当然，不断改名更困难，
I mean, this guy to Thorpe, I think, is nothing. In the TV drama, Russell T. Davis, the writer of the drama, kind of creates this very tragic and sort of sense that it was a kind of frustrated or doomed romance, that there was something that could have been bigger than it was. But I think in reality, Thorpe didn't really think anything of Norman Joseph or Scott as he became. He was just a passing fancy among many young men that he picked up and dropped. But for Norman, this looms larger and larger in his mind. And he thinks that Jeremy Thorpe has betrayed him. And crucially, that Jeremy Thorpe has stolen his national insurance card.
但他只是痴迷于这张该死的卡，并认为杰里米·索普正在阻挠他获得新卡的尝试。所以这一切本来没什么。如果不是因为两件事，这一切都无关紧要。杰里米·索普在自由党内的明星地位正在上升，但政治本身在60年代的英国也变得越来越狂热，因为英国的相对衰落变得越来越明显。所以换句话说，自由党从1950年代的笑话，将要在舞台上扮演越来越大的角色。这意味着索普本人将变得更像一个公众人物。这就是发生的事情。他成为了自由党的领袖。所以杰里米·索普成为了自由党的领袖。那是在同性恋除罪化之前还是之后，那是67年？是的，就在之前。所以他在1967年1月成为自由党领袖。但同性恋除罪化我想是在稍后一点。嗯，那并不重要，重要的是耻辱感依然存在，对于那些我认为已经成长起来的人，你知道，人们在阴影中度过了那么长时间，过着非法性生活或被认为是非法的生活，我不认为仅仅因为法律改变了，你知道，就会变成“万岁，我可以……”。对于年轻听众来说，很难理解当时的耻辱感有多大。我的意思是，是的，惊人的变化，惊人的社会变化。嗯，这可能是我们一生中最大的变化之一，汤姆，我想。这可能是单一最大的道德、文化变化，不是吗？
Okay, so we come back to that. Yeah, so the national insurance, you get a sense of how sort of slightly disturbed this guy Joseph is. That the national insurance card, I mean, people must have been losing their national insurance cards all the time in 60s Britain. You know, I mean, the government must have been deluged by people saying, I've lost my national insurance card, can I get a new one? Of course, it's more difficult to keep changing your name,
是的，绝对是。即使在我们成长为70年代的时候，它被彻底污名化的程度。所以当同性恋完全合法时，仍然存在耻辱感。对于像索普这样的人，你知道，比我们大一两代，这一定感觉几乎就像他每天都在……你知道，他头上顶着一个巨大的箭头走来走去，有一天人们会注意到，那将是一切的终结。我的意思是，这一定非常可怕。所以这就是让
but he's just obsessed with this bloody card and thinks that Jeremy Thorpe is frustrating his attempts to get a new one. So this would all be nothing. This would be immaterial, were it not, for two things. Jeremy Thorpe's star is rising within the Liberal Party, but also politics itself is becoming more and more febrile in 60s Britain, as sort of Britain's relative decline becomes more and more apparent. So in other words, the Liberal Party, from being this joke in the 1950s, is going to assume a bigger and bigger sort of role on the stage. And that means that Thorpe himself is going to become much more of a public figure. And that's what happens. He becomes leader of the Liberal Party. So Jeremy Thorpe becomes leader of the Liberal Party. Is that before or after the decriminalisation
诺曼·斯科特对他日益强烈的要求成为焦虑的原因。随着索普在自由党内地位的上升，这些要求变得越来越强烈，然后进入70年代，这是一个政治动荡的时期。索普是一个参与者。他不仅仅是在边缘。他是一个可能最终进入政府的人，因为权力平衡意味着自由党可能会进来并参与联合政府。所以没错。
of homosexuality, which is 67? Yeah, it's just before. So he becomes leader of the Liberal Party in January 1967. But homosexuality is decriminalised i think a little later um now that's that doesn't really matter what matters is that the the stigma is still there and for people i think who've grown up as it were you know people have spent so long as it were in the shadows leading illicit sex lives or lives that are perceived to be illicit i don't think just because the law has changed you know it becomes kind of hurrah i can it's hard for maybe younger listeners to appreciate just how great the stigma was i mean it's yeah astonishing change it's astonishing societal change well it's probably one of the biggest in our lifetime tom i would imagine it's probably the single biggest kind of moral cultural cultural change, isn't it?
所以突然间，这——对听节目的老派自由党人没有冒犯之意——但突然间，那个50年代的轻微笑话政党，到1974年肯定可以掌握权力平衡，而索普，这个基本上一直在驾驶这辆破旧车辆的流氓，突然间他可以在最高层占有一席之地。而问题是
Yeah, absolutely. The extent to which it was utterly stigmatized, even when we were growing up in kind of 70s. So when homosexuality was perfectly legal, there was still the stigma. And for somebody like Thorpe, you know, a generation or two older, it must have felt almost like every day he was you know he was walking around with a kind of giant arrow over his head and that one day people are going to notice and that then that would be the end of everything i mean it must have been utterly terrifying so that is what makes um
对索普来说，他是一个非常风趣的人，他是一个花花公子，他很受欢迎，他比另外两个政党领袖泰德·希思（Ted Heath）和哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）年轻。他们俩在人们看来都有点“陈旧”。他们一直在与工会领袖进行无休止的谈判，你知道，不断地出现在新闻上，
norman scott's increasingly importunate demands on him, a cause of anxiety. And these demands are becoming more and more importunate the higher that Thorpe rises up the Liberal Party, becomes leader, and then going into the 70s, it's a period of immense political turmoil. And Thorpe is a player. He's not just on the periphery. He's someone who might actually end up in the government because the balance of power means that the liberals might come in and take part in the coalition. So exactly.
并向全国发表广播，宣布坏消息，说电力将被切断之类的。而索普很年轻，他很浮夸，他很风趣。他有帽子。是的。人们说，嗯，他是一股新鲜空气。人们喜欢戴帽子的人。他们确实喜欢。
So suddenly this, I mean, no offence to kind of antiquated liberals listening, but suddenly the slight joke party from the 50s, certainly by 1974, could hold the balance of power and Thorpe, this sort of bounder who's been basically driving this rackety old vehicle, suddenly he could have a place at the top table. And the thing
我的意思是，谁不喜欢戴帽子的人呢？没人。嗯，除了卢·斯莫雷尔斯。约翰·F·肯尼迪。我相信他是第一位在就职典礼上不戴帽子的总统。据说，他一夜之间摧毁了帽子，因为他不想让帽子弄乱他漂亮的头发。我想那个名字恰如其分的卢·斯莫雷尔斯会赞同的。
is for Thorpe, he's a very funny man, he's a dandy, he's popular, he's younger than the other two-party leaders, Ted Heath and Howard Wilson. They both look a bit kind of shop-soiled to people. They've been sort of endless negotiations with union leaders and, you know, constantly going on the news
是的。所以无论如何，斯科特现在一直在纠缠。抱歉，约瑟夫改名叫斯科特了。这是一件奇怪、令人困惑的事情。所以他一直在纠缠索普要钱。而且，你知道，为什么他不回复我的信？为什么他不？就在那时，我想，如果相信索普审判中检方的陈述，
and sort of making broadcasts to the nation with bad news that the power is going to be cut off or something. And Thorpe is young, he's flamboyant, he's funny. He's got hats. Yeah. People say, well, he's a breath of fresh air. People love a man with a hat. They do.
就在那时，索普决定只有一个解决办法。他必须杀了他。也许我们应该休息一下。我们绝对应该休息一下。所以杰里米·索普，自由党领袖，70年代中期英国的潜在造王者，可能已经决定他需要谋杀他的情人。别走开。休息后我们回来。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们一起主持《历史的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先
I mean, who doesn't like a man with a hat? Nobody. Well, apart from loose morals. John F. Kennedy. He was the first president not to wear a hat at his inauguration, I believe. Supposedly, he destroyed hats overnight because he didn't want a hat to mess up his nice hair. I think the aptly named loose morals would approve of.
观看现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们正在谈论杰里米·索普丑闻。嗯，当……当我们离开你进行商业休息时，多米尼克已经为我们做了精彩的铺垫。多米尼克，杰里米·索普所谓的密谋除掉诺曼·斯科特的计划。我为刚才差点笑出来道歉。这是一件可怕的事情。不，但这正是这个故事奇怪的地方。它既是黑色幽默又是悲剧，不是吗？是的。
Yeah. So anyway, so Scott is all the time now badgering. Sorry, Josephus changed his name to Scott. That's one strange, confusing thing. So he's all the time badgering Thorpe for money. And for, you know, why doesn't he respond to my letters? Why doesn't he? And it's at that point, I think, that if the account of the prosecution at Thorpe's trial is to believe,
好的，那么给我们讲讲发生了什么。他的计划是什么？所以发生的事情是，在60年代末，索普已经——他有几个亲信参与其中。他说，你知道，我被这个不肯放过我的家伙纠缠。他到处乱跑。斯科特甚至写了一封信给索普的母亲，说，
it's at that point that Thorpe decides there's only one solution. He's going to have to kill him. And maybe we should take a break. We should absolutely take a break. So Jeremy Thorpe, leader of the Liberal Party, the potential kingmaker in mid-70s Britain, may possibly have decided that he needs to murder his lover. Don't go away. We'll be back after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early
如你所知，杰里米和我有过同性恋关系。他引诱了我，所有这些事情。所以他真的在折磨索普。索普有两个亲信。一个是叫大卫·霍姆斯（David Holmes）的人，他是一个自由党的跟班。另一个是叫彼得·贝塞尔（Peter Bessell）的自由党议员，他是一个非常狡猾的人，最终因欺诈逃离该国，
access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. hello welcome back to the rest is history we are talking the jeremy thorpe scandal um when uh when we we left you for the commercial break um dominic was had set us up beautifully um dominic jeremy thorpe's supposed alleged plot to have Norman Scott done away with. And I apologise for almost laughing there. It's a terrible thing. No, but that's the weird thing about this story. It's both blackly comic and tragic, isn't it? Yes.
并在加利福尼亚定居。这就是索普决定卷入的两个人。他说，你们能基本上把斯科特打发走吗？但斯科特不肯闭嘴。所以他开始进行这些对话，索普说，嗯，我认为要做的就是杀了他。我们应该……不肯闭嘴。所以他开始进行这些对话，索普说，嗯，我认为要做的就是杀了他。我们应该安排谋杀他。现在索普后来又说，嗯，这只是个玩笑。我的意思是，在某个时候他说，
Okay, so talk us through what happens. What are his plans? So what's happened is at the end of the 60th, Thorpe has been – he's got a couple of sort of cronies involved in this. And he said, you know, I'm being hassled by this bloke who won't leave me alone. He's going round. Scott has even written a letter to Thorpe's mother saying,
贝塞尔声称索普说这不会比射杀一只病狗更糟糕，考虑到他们确实做过，一只狗最终确实死了。这似乎……我想这是一个可能被编造的细节。但无论如何，据我所知，索普提出了三个方案。一个是他的朋友大卫·霍姆斯应该伪装成一名德国商人，然后在德文郡的一家酒吧里扭断斯科特的脖子之类的。那没用，因为霍姆斯从来没有……我的意思是，
as you know, Jeremy and I have had a homosexual relationship. He seduced me and all this sort of stuff. So he's really plaguing Thorpe. And Thorpe has two cronies. One is a guy called David Holmes, who's a kind of liberal flunky. And the other is a liberal MP called Peter Bessel, who is a very dodgy person who ends up fleeing the country for fraud
我不认为他曾经……扭断过别人的脖子。不，我不认为他曾经打过架。对自由党公平一点。所以这是方案一。方案二，霍姆斯要把斯科特引诱到酒吧，在他的饮料里下毒，让他死掉，然后把他的尸体扔进埃克斯穆尔（Exmoor）的一个矿井里。
and settling in California. And these are the two men that Thorpe decides to involve. And he says, can you basically pay Scott off? But Scott won't shut up. So he starts to have these conversations where Thorpe says, well, I think the thing to do is just to kill him. We should won't shut up. So he starts to have these conversations where Thorpe says, well, I think the thing to do is just to kill him. We should arrange to murder him. And now Thorpe says later, well, this was all just a joke. I mean, at one point he says,
霍姆斯说那行不通，因为如果他……为什么他叫霍姆斯？这给整件事增加了一层额外的怪异和模仿感。最近有人说，那怎么行得通？如果我在酒吧里在他的饮料里下毒，他会在酒吧里死掉，每个人都会看到，我不能把他的尸体偷运出去扔
Bessel claims that Thorpe said it would be no worse than shooting a sick dog, which given that they did, a dog does end up dying. It seems, I think that's a detail that's probably invented. But anyway, so there are three schemes, I think, as far as I understand it, that Thorpe suggested. One is that his friend David Holmes should disguise himself as a German businessman and then break Scott's neck in a pub in Devon or something. That was no good because Holmes had never, I mean,
进矿井里，所以那行不通。索普说，好吧，把他引诱到佛罗里达，进入大沼泽地，让他被短吻鳄吃掉。这就像汤姆·夏普（Tom Sharp）的小说，不是吗？这不是《随身携带》（Carry On）系列。这是一部汤姆·夏普的小说。确实是。
I don't think he'd ever... Broken someone's neck. No, I don't think he'd ever had a fight. To be fair to the Liberal Party. So that's idea one. Idea two is that Holmes is going to lure Scott to the pub, poison his drink so that he dies, and then throw his body down a mine shaft on Exmoor.
看，这就是你可以说索普很可能说“我在开玩笑”的地方。因为你可以看出那是在喝酒时失控的谈话。所以他们谈论了这个，但有一段时间什么也没发生。然后我想你到了1974年，突然间索普不仅仅是一颗冉冉升起的新星。突然间他就在那里了。他上了头条，因为泰德·希思，首相，在国家绝对要完蛋的情况下召集了选举，
Holmes says that won't work because if he... Why is he called Holmes? It adds an extra level of weirdness and parody to the whole thing quite recently says how will that work like if I poison his drink in the pub it'll die in the pub everybody will see I can't smuggle his body out and throw
矿工们罢工，灯光熄灭。泰德·希思召集选举以获得新的授权，结果完全搞砸了。出现了悬浮议会，希思与索普进行了联合政府谈判。这种谈话不是说索普要成为内政大臣吗？索普此时将成为内政大臣。所以他将负责他自己的起诉。军情五处（MI5）有一份关于索普的档案，你知道，有一英寸厚，所有这些……
it down a mine so that's no go and Thorpe says fine lure him to Florida, into the Everglades, and have him eaten by alligators. It's like Tom Sharp, actually, isn't it? It's not Carry On. It's a Tom Sharp novel. It is.
因为斯科特一直在告诉所有人。斯科特一直在伦敦到处跑，给人们写信，告诉人们，并拦住他们说，杰里米·索普是我的情人，他背叛了我，他拿走了我的国民保险卡。爱德华·希思（Edward Heath）不知道这件事吗？我想，你看，大多数政治家认为这完全是疯了。他们不相信斯科特。
See, that's the point at which you can say, Thorpe might well say, I was joking. Because you can kind of see how that is a conversation with over drinks that's kind of got out of hand. So they talk about this, but nothing really happens for a while. And then I guess you get to 1974 and suddenly Thorpe is not just a rising star. Suddenly he's kind of in there. He's on the front pages because Ted Heath, the prime Minister, has called an election with the country absolutely going to pot
他们认为斯科特是在编造这一切。他们知道索普是同性恋，但他们不认为，你知道，斯科特的事情真的有什么实质内容。他们认为这只是因为在那个阶段，它真的没什么实质内容。我的意思是，它，你知道，几乎对他有好处。你可以说他们不认为这完全剥夺了索普……你知道，几乎对他有好处。你可以说他们不认为这完全剥夺了索普……你知道，上流社会。他们只是想，嗯，杰里米，每个人都知道他有一个混乱的私生活。
and the miners out on strike and the lights going out. Ted Heath calls an election to get a new mandate and it completely goes wrong. There's a hung parliament and Heath has coalition talks with Thorpe. And this talk isn't that Thorpe is going to become Home Secretary? Thorpe would become Home Secretary at this point. So he'd be responsible for his own prosecution. MI5, have a file on Thorpe, you know, an inch thick with all these.
这个家伙让他的生活变得悲惨，这完全是不公平的。让那个没有密谋通过把他扔给佛罗里达的短吻鳄来杀死男朋友的人投下第一块石头吧。他们不知道在那个阶段这已经发生了。所以1974年2月、3月，索普进行了这些联合政府谈判，但没有成功。所以他没有进入政府。相反，哈罗德·威尔逊回来了，工党领袖，他成为了首相。
Because Scott has been telling everybody. Scott has been going around London, writing letters to people and telling people and buttonholing them and saying, Jeremy Thorpe was my lover and he has betrayed me and he's got my national insurance card. Is Edward Heath not aware of this? I think, you see, most politicians think this is just completely mad. They don't believe Scott.
然后1974年10月进行了第二次选举。索普在2月获得了20%的选票，他希望在10月取得重大突破。而他的重大策略，嗯，不是他的重大策略，那是夸张，但他的一种噱头是他要租一艘气垫船，坐着这艘气垫船在西南部到处跑。因为气垫船传达了一种……
They think Scott is making it all up. They know that Thorpe is gay, but they don't think, you know, that the Scott stuff really amounts to anything. They think it's just because at that stage, it doesn't really amount to anything. I mean, it's, you know, it almost reflects well on them. You could say they don't think this debars Thorpe completely from, you know, it almost reflects well on them. You could say they don't think this debars thought completely from, you know, polite society. They just think, well, Jeremy, everybody knows he's got a rackety private life.
他们认为斯科特是在编造这一切。他们知道索普是同性恋，但他们认为，你知道，斯科特说的那些事根本算不了什么。他们认为这只是因为在那个阶段，这确实算不了什么。我的意思是，这，你知道，这几乎对他们来说是一种正面的反映。你可以说他们并不认为这会完全剥夺索普进入，你知道，上流社会的资格。他们只是觉得，好吧，杰里米，大家都知道他的私生活很混乱。
It's completely unfair that this guy is making his life a misery. Let he who is not plotted to kill his boyfriend by throwing him to an alligator in Florida cast the first stone. They don't know that that stage this has happened. So February 19th, March 1974, Thorpe has these coalition talks and they don't work out. So he doesn't go into government. Instead, Harold Wilson comes back, a Labour leader, and he becomes prime minister.
这个家伙让他的生活变得痛苦不堪，这完全是不公平的。谁没有策划过在佛罗里达把男朋友扔给鳄鱼吃掉，谁就先扔石头吧。他们不知道在那个阶段已经发生了这件事。所以1974年2月19日，3月，索普进行了这些联合政府谈判，但没有成功。所以他没有进入政府。相反，哈罗德·威尔逊回来了，作为工党领袖，他成为了首相。
Then there's a second election in October 1974. Thorpe is on 20% of the vote in February and he's hoping for a big breakthrough in October. And his big strategy, well, not his big strategy, that's an exaggeration, but one of his gimmicks is he's going to hire a hovercraft and travel around the southwest in this hovercraft. Because hovercraft conveys a sense of...
然后是1974年10月的第二次选举。索普在2月份获得了20%的选票，他希望在10月份能有重大突破。他的一大策略，好吧，不是什么大策略，那是夸张了，但他的一项噱头是他要租一艘气垫船，乘着这艘气垫船在西南部到处走。因为气垫船传达了一种……的感觉
Modernity. Future, modernity, white heat of technology. When Britain is in a shambles in 1974, you've got IRA bombs going off in pubs, inflation is through the roof, trade union is out on strike. If you've got a hover going off in pubs inflation is through the roof trade union is out on strike if you've got a hovercraft that shows you own the future it's kind of doctor who your future and the hovercraft breaks down it does British made hovercraft or something it's like breaks down a thought has to wade ashore in the eyes of the press and his campaign kind of goes
现代性。未来、现代性、科技的白热化。1974年的英国一片混乱，酒吧里有爱尔兰共和军的炸弹爆炸，通货膨胀高得离谱，工会正在罢工。如果你有一艘气垫船，那表明你拥有未来，这有点像《神秘博士》里的未来，但气垫船坏了，那是英国制造的气垫船，坏了之后，在媒体眼中，他不得不涉水上岸，他的竞选活动也随之……
similarly you know people have had their fun kind of voting for the liberals earlier in the year but now it becomes a much more of a choice i think um between labor and the tories the liberal vote dips and there's a sort of sense of a deflated balloon and it's round about this point that i mean i'm not entire i don't think anyone is entirely sure of the precise chronology because of course it's disputed but it's about this point that basically they're pressed go on the murder plan and not surprisingly because Thorpe thinks I've got it all to lose now you know I'm in the big league and I can't have Scott hanging
同样，你知道人们在年初投票给自由党是为了找乐子，但现在这变成了一个更艰难的选择，我想是在工党和保守党之间，自由党的选票下降了，有一种气球泄气的感觉，就在这一点上，我的意思是，我不确定，我不认为有人能完全确定具体的时间顺序，因为这当然是有争议的，但就在这一点上，基本上他们决定执行谋杀计划，这并不奇怪，因为索普认为我现在失去了一切，你知道，我进入了顶级联赛，我不能让斯科特挂在
around we've just got to get rid of him so it's at that point that and I've actually made a chart to remind myself because it's so... I think this is a first I think you know we've done all these topics and I don't think we've ever had a chart before.
身边，我们必须除掉他，所以就在那一刻，我实际上做了一张图表来提醒自己，因为它太……我想这是第一次，我想你知道我们做过所有这些主题，我不认为我们以前有过图表。
No, so I've got... Listen, this is a first. Dominic is unveiling the first The Rest Is History chart. So what happens? Thorpe gets... He says to Holmes, his mate, the aptly named Holmes, he says, you have to sort this out now. You have to kill Norman Scott.
不，所以我有了……听着，这是第一次。多米尼克正在揭晓第一张《历史余韵》图表。那么发生了什么？索普被……他对他的伙伴福尔摩斯说，那个名字很贴切的福尔摩斯，他说，你现在必须解决这个问题。你必须杀了诺曼·斯科特。
He's still pestering me with his letters, his bloody national insurance demands, and I want to be prime minister. So Holmes, pestering me with his letters, his bloody national insurance demands. And I want to be prime minister. So Holmes, he's never arranged a hit in his life. He's never arranged anything even vaguely approaching. I mean, which of us has? So he enlists the help of a carpet salesman from South Wales who he knows.
他还在用他的信件、他该死的国民保险要求来纠缠我，而我想成为首相。所以福尔摩斯，用他的信件、他该死的国民保险要求来纠缠我。而我想成为首相。所以福尔摩斯，他这辈子从来没安排过谋杀。他从来没安排过任何类似的事情。我的意思是，我们谁安排过？所以他寻求了一位他认识的南威尔士地毯推销员的帮助。
I don't know if the world of selling carpets is particularly violent in the 70s. But this guy is called John LeMessurier. Okay, which to anyone who's watched Dad's Army, the actor John LeMessurier plays Sergeant Wilson. He is, who was one of the big stars of the British small screen in the 70s. But it's not him. It's somebody else with the same very uncommon name.
我不知道70年代的地毯销售世界是否特别暴力。但这家伙叫约翰·勒梅苏里尔。好吧，对于任何看过《老爸上战场》的人来说，演员约翰·勒梅苏里尔饰演威尔逊中士。他是70年代英国小荧幕上的大明星之一。但不是他。是另一个同名同姓的人。
John LeMessurier says, well, he doesn't know anything about arranging murders, but he knows a man who might, who's a man called George Deacon, who supplies fruit machines to pubs and hotels. So, you know, slot machines, basically. Now, the slot machine world was actually, you know, no place for kind of shrinking violence. There was a lot of corruption, and there were slightly shady elements to the slot machine world was actually you know not no place for kind of shrinking violence there was a lot of corruption and it was there were slightly shady elements to the slot machine world so this
约翰·勒梅苏里尔说，好吧，他对安排谋杀一窍不通，但他认识一个可能知道的人，那个人叫乔治·迪肯，他为酒吧和酒店供应水果机。所以，你知道，基本上就是老虎机。现在，老虎机世界实际上，你知道，并不是一个胆小鬼待的地方。那里有很多腐败，老虎机世界里有一些稍微阴暗的元素，所以这
is not entirely ridiculous so now we've got a few stages away from thorpe deacon i think he approaches him in the pub or something he he then finds a prospective hitman this man is a man called andrew or gino as he called himself gino Newton. Newton, he's not an ideal assassin because he's never shot anybody. And he's actually an airline pilot. But basically, he says, I'll do it. You know, I'll do it. And they say they'll pay him £10,000, I think it is, which is a lot of money. His salary is £6,000, right? Yeah, exactly. So that tells you how much money he's being offered. So later on, they said, oh, we never paid him to shoot him. We just paid him to blackmail him.
并不完全荒谬，所以现在我们离索普还有几个阶段，我想迪肯在酒吧或其他地方接近了他，然后他找到了一个潜在的杀手，这个人叫安德鲁，或者他自称吉诺·牛顿。牛顿，他不是一个理想的刺客，因为他从来没杀过人。他实际上是一名航空公司飞行员。但基本上，他说，我会做的。你知道，我会做的。他们说会付给他1万英镑，我想是这样，这是一大笔钱。他的薪水是6000英镑，对吧？是的，没错。所以这告诉你他被提供了多少钱。所以后来，他们说，哦，我们从来没付钱让他杀他。我们只是付钱让他勒索他。
But as he pointed out, you wouldn't give me that much money if it was just for blackmailing him. You're giving me more than my salary as an airline pilot. And airline pilots are well paid. So he's going to do it. I mean, God knows why he said yes. Maybe he just needed the money. I mean, he says, I norman scott for you so in the autumn of 1975
但正如他指出的，如果只是为了勒索他，你不会给我那么多钱。你给我的比我作为航空公司飞行员的薪水还多。而且航空公司飞行员薪水很高。所以他打算这么做。我的意思是，天知道他为什么答应。也许他只是需要钱。我的意思是，他说，我为你处理诺曼·斯科特，所以在1975年秋天
he goes off to um uh sort of devon somerset sort of borderlands x more yeah minehead exactly and um he meets norman scott you know what his story is to lure norman scott now he says um somebody's trying to kill you. I'll protect you. It's very unimaginative. Very subtle. There's another hitman. Weirdly, Scott kind of goes along with it. And at one
他去了德文郡、萨默塞特郡的边界地带，埃克斯穆尔，没错，迈恩黑德，没错，他遇到了诺曼·斯科特，你知道他引诱诺曼·斯科特的借口是什么吗？他说，有人想杀你。我会保护你的。非常缺乏想象力。非常微妙。还有另一个杀手。奇怪的是，斯科特竟然顺从了。在某
point, Newton says to him, well, listen, let's go for a drive. Isn't that the odd thing that Norman Scott is a paranoid fantasist? Whose worst paranoid fantasies actually turn out to be true? Yeah, but also doesn't seem to is a paranoid fantasist whose worst paranoid fantasies actually turn out to be true. Yeah, but also doesn't seem to... A paranoid fantasist who doesn't recognise
一点上，牛顿对他说，好吧，听着，我们去兜兜风吧。诺曼·斯科特是一个偏执的幻想家，这难道不奇怪吗？他最糟糕的偏执幻想竟然成真了？是的，但似乎……一个偏执的幻想家，他没有意识到
when the hitman finally pitches up. Yeah. So Newton says, I'll take you on a drive. It's from a place called Coomartin to a place called Porlock, so it's kind of over Exmoor. And Newton is thrown at the outset of the journey because Scott has brought his dog with him, who's this
当杀手最终出现时。是的。所以牛顿说，我带你去兜兜风。是从一个叫库马丁的地方到一个叫波洛克的地方，所以大概是穿过埃克斯穆尔。牛顿在旅程开始时就很困惑，因为斯科特带了他的狗，就是那只
great Dane called Rinker. They set off and Newton is really nervous. I mean, you'd be nervous anyway. You're going to kill somebody and you've never done it. He's got an antique Mauser pistol, a German kind of wartime pistol. And he's allergic to dogs or something. He has a horror of dogs. Yes. So Scott has brought
叫林克的丹麦大狗。他们出发了，牛顿非常紧张。我的意思是，你无论如何都会紧张。你要杀人，而你从来没做过。他有一把古董毛瑟手枪，一种德国战时手枪。而且他对狗过敏还是什么的。他非常怕狗。是的。所以斯科特带了
his dog. And Newton is, you can imagine driving the car over the bloody moorland, pitch black, probably raining. And of the Baskervilles. There's his dog. There's his dog. And you know you've got to kill this guy and probably the dog as well. And you've never shot, you know,
他的狗。牛顿，你可以想象开车穿过该死的荒原，漆黑一片，可能还在下雨。巴斯克维尔猎犬。那是他的狗。那是他的狗。你知道你必须杀了这家伙，可能还有那只狗。而你从来没开过枪，你知道，
you've never killed anyone before in your life. He gets halfway and he sort of panics or something. Or there's some talk about swapping drivers and they pull over the dog assumes when they pull over that it's time to go for a walk and leaps out of the car so scott gets out after the dog and newton the hitman he gets out as well and he thinks christ i've got to do something so he just shoots the dog kills the dog i mean that's the that's something. So he just shoots the dog, kills the dog. I mean, that's the tragedy of the whole story. The dog is the real loser. Scott says, oh, my God, you've shot my dog.
你这辈子从来没杀过人。他走到一半，他有点恐慌还是什么的。或者有一些关于换驾驶员的谈话，他们靠边停车，狗以为他们靠边停车是要去散步，于是跳出了车，所以斯科特跟着狗下车了，牛顿这个杀手也下车了，他想，天哪，我必须做点什么，所以他直接开枪打死了狗，杀死了狗，我的意思是，这真是……所以他直接开枪打死了狗，杀死了狗。我的意思是，这是整个故事的悲剧。狗才是真正的输家。斯科特说，哦，天哪，你打死了我的狗。
What are you doing? What are you doing? Newton, I mean, this is an incredible detail now, Tom. He points the gun. He puts it to Scott's head and pulls the trigger. And nothing happens. The gun jams. So Newton then just gets back in the car and drives
你在干什么？你在干什么？牛顿，我的意思是，这是一个令人难以置信的细节，汤姆。他用枪指着。他把它抵在斯科特的头上并扣动了扳机。什么也没发生。枪卡壳了。所以牛顿就直接回到车里开车
off, which is ludicrous. I mean, at least try to batter him to death or something. Don't leave him there with the dead dog. That's what he does. So Scott has, you know, he's just been taken for a lift by this bloke who's shot his dog and then driven off into
走了，这太荒谬了。我的意思是，至少试着把他打死或者什么的。别把他和死狗留在那里。但他就是这么做的。所以斯科特，你知道，他只是被这个家伙载了一程，这家伙打死了他的狗，然后开车驶入了
the mist. And he comes to the only obvious conclusion. This has been arranged by Jeremy Thorpe. Which it has. Or has it? And then he goes around for the next few months basically making court appearances and telling everyone who will listen
迷雾中。他得出了唯一明显的结论。这是杰里米·索普安排的。确实是。或者真的是吗？然后他在接下来的几个月里基本上到处出庭，告诉每一个愿意听的人
I have been, you know, Jeremy Thorpe has tried to assassinate me. But presumably it sounds so mad that nobody believes him. Nobody believes it at all. Well, so how does it come, how does it come, I mean, how do people end up starting to believe him?
我已经，你知道，杰里米·索普试图暗杀我。但大概这听起来太疯狂了，没人相信他。根本没人相信。好吧，那么它是怎么，它是怎么，我的意思是，人们最终是怎么开始相信他的？
So just on nobody believing him, the government know about it. Harold Wilson knows about it. But Harold Wilson thinks he's being framed by the South African intelligence service who are called BOSS. Yes, okay. So we've got a question from Andrew Harrison. Were BOSS really involved? So this is the really weird aspect of this story. In the 1970s, everything had gone wrong for
关于没人相信他，政府知道这件事。哈罗德·威尔逊知道这件事。但哈罗德·威尔逊认为他被南非情报局（BOSS）陷害了。是的，好吧。所以我们有一个来自安德鲁·哈里森的问题。BOSS真的参与了吗？所以这是这个故事非常奇怪的一面。在1970年代，一切对
Britain. And so there was this sort of general sense, weirdly, particularly among the people who should have known better, the top of the sort of governments and stuff, that this must be because of evil conspiracies by sort of shadowy intelligence agents and stuff. So Howard Wilson, who is the Labour Prime Minister, who we saw coming back to power in 1974, everything is going wrong for him. And he thinks he is being plotted against by MI5
英国来说都出了问题。所以有一种普遍的感觉，奇怪的是，特别是在那些本应更了解情况的人，即政府高层中，认为这一定是因为某种阴暗情报特工的邪恶阴谋。所以哈罗德·威尔逊，那位工党首相，我们看到他在1974年重掌政权，一切对他来说都在出错。他认为军情五处
and also by the South African Secret Service boss. I mean, who would call... what do you, why would you call your Secret Service BOSS? It's always as good as Spectre. Yeah, it's the Bureau of State Security, but even so, I mean, what a name. Anyway, he thinks BOSS is plotting against him. And so, Howard Wilson is saying to his cabinet ministers,
以及南非秘密情报局BOSS都在密谋反对他。我的意思是，谁会叫……你为什么会把你的秘密情报局叫BOSS？这和“幽灵党”一样好。是的，那是国家安全局，但即便如此，我的意思是，这名字真绝。总之，他认为BOSS在密谋反对他。所以，哈罗德·威尔逊对他的内阁大臣们说，
you're hearing all these rumours about Thorpe. They're all created by BOSS. BOSS are involved with this. And BOSS do, in fact, know about it they hate thorpe because he's been campaigning against apartheid but they haven't created this story they've just sort of picked it up and are delighted by it and hoping to use it against him so the way it starts to look more um uh the way people start to believe the thorpe story is that scott starts to give his letters to the newspapers.
你们听到了所有关于索普的传言。它们都是BOSS制造的。BOSS参与了这件事。而且BOSS实际上确实知道这件事，他们讨厌索普，因为他一直在反对种族隔离，但他们并没有编造这个故事，他们只是捡起来，并为此感到高兴，希望利用它来对付他，所以事情开始看起来更……人们开始相信索普故事的方式是斯科特开始把他的信件交给报纸。
He's got this cache of letters, you see. That's one of the big things. He's got the letters that show that he and Thorpe did have a relationship. But also Thorpe's old crony, Peter Bessel, who's moved to California, he starts talking to the newspapers as well. So now you've got a feeding frenzy, fleet street feeding frenzy as the newspapers are competing for ever more lurid allegations and one of the things that makes this story very hard to assess is we don't know and we'll never know how much some of these anecdotes have been concocted to sell you know by the people telling them to sell papers for example the line it's no better than
他有一批信件，你看。这是大事件之一。他有那些显示他和索普确实有关系的信件。而且索普的老密友彼得·贝塞尔，他搬到了加利福尼亚，他也开始和报纸交谈。所以现在你有了疯狂的抢购，舰队街的疯狂抢购，因为报纸在竞争更耸人听闻的指控，而让这个故事很难评估的事情之一是，我们不知道，也永远不会知道，这些轶事中有多少是为了卖报纸而被编造出来的，例如那句“这不比
shooting a sick dog yeah i think bessel made that up because it was such a great line and he could you know the telegraph or the mail or whoever it was would run with them but i mean it's a kind of intriguing reminder of the pre-internet era that it takes this long to spill out yeah yes now it would all be out in a couple of hours wouldn't it yeah so it does take a very you're're right, it takes a very long time. So the sort of attempted murder is the autumn of 1975. But then it's not till May 1976 that Thorpe steps down as leader of the Liberal Party, because the Sunday Times had printed some of his letters to Norman Scott. And then the case rumbles on for a few more years.
射杀一只病狗好多少”，是的，我认为贝塞尔编造了那句话，因为它是一句很棒的台词，他可以，你知道，《每日电讯报》或《每日邮报》或任何报纸都会刊登它们，但我的意思是，这是一个关于前互联网时代的有趣提醒，它花了这么长时间才泄露出来，是的，是的，现在这一切会在几个小时内传开，不是吗？是的，所以确实花了很长时间，你是对的，花了很长时间。所以那次谋杀未遂是在1975年秋天。但直到1976年5月，索普才辞去自由党领袖职务，因为《星期日泰晤士报》刊登了他写给诺曼·斯科特的一些信件。然后案件又拖了几年。
And there's kind of revelation after revelation, this slow drip, drip, drip in the newspapers. And the other thing that I should have mentioned is that one of the key people in pushing the story, who's another great character who actually didn't really appear so much, I think, in a very English scandal, is the satirist Oberon Waugh. So he's Evelyn Waugh's son, the son of the Bridesmaid revisited novelist.
而且有各种各样的揭露，报纸上这种缓慢的滴水穿石。我应该提到的另一件事是，推动这个故事的关键人物之一，另一个伟大的角色，我想他并没有在《英式丑闻》中出现太多，就是讽刺作家奥伯伦·沃。所以他是伊夫林·沃的儿子，那位《旧地重游》小说家的儿子。
He lives down in the West Country, doesn't he? He lives in the West Country. He knows of Thorpe. And he writes a diary for Private Eye magazine in which he makes stuff up. So he writes this incredibly reactionary diary in which he sort of says, I went to dinner with Princess Margaret last
他住在西南部，不是吗？他住在西南部。他认识索普。他为《私家侦探》杂志写日记，在日记里他编造东西。所以他写了这篇极其反动的日记，在日记里他说，我昨晚和玛格丽特公主共进晚餐，我们一致认为所有罢工者都应该被当场枪决，或者类似的话。但在70年代他的日记过程中，他确实对索普怀有深仇大恨。我的意思是，他称自己为复仇者。他说索普是个伪君子和骗子。他有令人作呕和反感的个人习惯。他特别对杀死林克感到不安。
night and we agreed that all strikers should be shot on sight, or something of this kind. But in the course of his diary over the 70s, he has a real vendetta against Thorpe. I mean, he just calls himself a vendetta. He says Thorpe is a hypocrite and a liar. He has disgusting and revolting personal habits. And he's particularly upset about the killing of Rinker.
是的。所以当他听说那只狗的事时，他说，这证实了我对索普的所有怀疑。索普是个杀狗凶手。真的，我的意思是，在英国，没有比杀狗凶手更糟糕的指控了。就是这样。杀死狗而不是……
Yeah. So when he hears about the dog, he says, this just confirms everything I've ever suspected about Thorpe. Thorpe is a dog murderer. And really, I mean, in England, there could be no worse accusation than a dog murderer. That's the thing. The killing of the dog rather than...
如果被谋杀的是斯科特，那故事就不会这么精彩了。不。这是一个更好的故事，因为是那只狗，林克，那只无辜的狗被杀了。所以在这段时间里，70年代的皇家检察署或他们那时的机构正在收集信息。他们决定起诉索普、福尔摩斯、水果机人乔治·迪肯、地毯推销员勒梅苏里尔、航空公司飞行员牛顿。
If it was Scott who was murdered, it wouldn't be such a good story. No. It's a better story because it's the dog, Rinker, the innocent dog who is killed. So before all this time, the sort of Crown Prosecution Service or whatever they were in the 70s are sort of amassing information. They decide they are going to charge Thorpe, Holmes, the fruit machine man, George Deakin, the carpet salesman, LeMessurier, the airline pilot, Newton.
他们要以共谋谋杀罪起诉他们所有人。但这直到下一次大选，即1979年大选之后才发生。所以这给了讽刺作家奥伯伦·沃机会去竞选对抗索普。代表狗党。是的，爱狗人士党。爱狗人士党，口号是“为你的狗争取更好的待遇”。为你的狗争取更好的待遇。所以他的竞选宣言被法律禁止了，因为法官说这会对审判造成偏见，因为奥伯伦·沃在为狗竞选，反对索普。他说狗在英国受到了非常糟糕的待遇。
They're going to charge them all with conspiracy to murder. But that doesn't happen until after the next general election, the 1979 general election. So that gives Auburn War, the satirist, the chance to stand against Thorpe. Running for the dog party. Yeah, the dog lover's party. Dog lover's party, with its slogan, a better deal for your dog. A better deal for your dog. So his election manifesto was suppressed by law because the judge said it would be prejudicial to the trial because Auburn War was campaigning for dogs and against Thorpe. He said dogs had had a very bad deal in Britain.
索普一直在到处杀它们。法官不让他出版。所以他赢得了79张选票，沃。而索普输了，不是吗？但实际上以一个令人惊讶的小差距，考虑到……是的，索普在他的地方选区有大量的支持。所以关于改变对同性恋态度的这个主题，
Thorpe had been going around killing them. And the judge wouldn't let him publish. So he won 79 votes, war. And Thorpe loses, doesn't he? But actually by a surprisingly small amount, considering... Yeah, there's tons of support for Thorpe in his local manner, as it were. And so on the theme of changing attitudes to homosexuality,
很多选民似乎根本不担心这一点。好吧，索普结婚了。索普结过两次婚，所以我想很多人只是不相信，汤姆，这是一种奇怪的事情，我想很多选民对索普产生了依恋，他们只是简单地拒绝相信他可能犯下任何他被指控的罪行，但他确实输了，是的，但他确实输了，然后在撒切尔夫人上台的大选之后，索普和另外三名共谋者在高等法院受审，是的，没错，在老贝利，在老贝利，是的，好吧，所以，所以，因为这是英国消失的另一个方面，那就是滑稽的反动、
lots of voters don't seem to be worried about that at all. Well, Thorpe is married. thorpe has been twice married um so a lot of people i think didn't just didn't believe it and it's that weird thing tom where i think a lot of voters had formed an attachment to thorpe and they just simply refused to believe that he could have been guilty of any of the things that he was accused of but he loses yeah but he does lose he loses and then after the election which sees mrs satchel come to power um thorpe comes to trial with the three other conspirators in the high court yes right in the old bailey in the old bailey yeah and okay so so so because this is another aspect of Britain that has vanished completely, is the tradition of the comically reactionary,
脱离现实的法官的传统。坎特利大法官，是吗？是的。坎特利大法官，是的。是的，他基本上主持了这个案件，他的总结陈词非常偏向索普，以至于索普被判无罪。
out-of-touch judge. Lord Justice Cantley, was it? Yes. Lord Justice Cantley, yeah. Yes. Who basically presides over the case, and his summing up is so weighted in Thorpe's favour that Thorpe gets acquitted.
是的，你有那个吗，汤姆？我没有，但著名的是它后来被彼得·库克模仿了，我的意思是，他基本上是资助《私家侦探》的人，达德利·摩尔和彼得·库克的一部分。他是《超越边缘》的一部分，是英国喜剧的天才。他做了这种几乎完美的模仿。好吧，坎特利描述了斯科特。
Yeah, have you got it there, Tom? I haven't, but famously it then gets parodied by Peter Cook, who's the, I mean, he's basically, he's the guy who funds Private Eye, part of Dudley Moore and Peter Cook. He was part of the Beyond the Fringe, kind of the great genius of British comedy. And he does this kind of almost pitch-perfect parody. Well, Canley had described Scott.
他在总结陈词中说，他说，索普先生，多年来一直担任公职，斯科特，寄生虫，伪君子，同性恋。而且，你知道，他完全加载了……正如你所说，彼得·库克做得非常出色。自称是“粉红双簧管”演奏者，这是
He'd said in his summing up, he'd said, Mr Thorpe, public servant of many years standing, Scott, scrounger, parasite, hypocrite, homosexual. And sort of, you know, he completely loaded the... As you say, Peter Cook does this absolutely brilliantly. Self-confessed player of the pink oboe, is the
那个短语。是的，我的意思是，他基本上所做的是，之所以那么好，是因为他基本上穿插了坎特利真正说过的话。是的。也许这就是原因之一，也许只是中年，但英国喜剧这些天似乎没那么好笑了。这是因为法官没那么好笑。
flavor's phrase. Yeah, I mean, basically what he does is, the reason that's so good is that he basically intersperses with what Cantney genuinely had said. Yeah. Maybe that's one of the reasons why why maybe it's just middle age, but British comedy doesn't seem quite as funny these days. It's because judges aren't as funny.
没什么可踢的。建制派人物没那么好笑，因为那时建制派确实是建制派，你可以，而现在建制派都和孩子们打成一片。所以他们没那么即时有趣。总之。所以对杰里米·索普来说太棒了。他被判无罪，但他的职业生涯，他的职业生涯被毁了，我的意思是，他必须被判无罪，我想汤姆，因为控方的案子几乎必然是非常薄弱的，一切都基于传闻，好吧，这里有一个乔纳森·梅策给你的问题，陪审团在
There's nothing to kick. Establishment figures aren't as funny because back then the establishment really was the establishment and you could, whereas now the establishment is all down with the kids. So they're not as instantly amusing. Anyway. So great for Jeremy Thorpe. He gets acquitted but his his career his career is destroyed i mean he had to be acquitted i think tom because the prosecution case almost necessarily was quite flimsy it's all based on hearsay okay so here's a question for you from jonathan metzer the jury acquitted on
“排除合理怀疑”的测试下判决无罪，但审视所有现有和当时的证据，索普是可能是有罪还是无罪？你怎么看？好吧，我认为陪审团必须判决无罪，因为那个……好吧，那不是问题，那不是问题，不，我只想说一件事，他们，那些关键的控方证人，结果证明，根据他们与报纸的交易，如果索普倒台，他们会得到更多的钱，所以我的意思是，这显然看起来非常……是的，所以如果索普倒台，他们会得到更多的钱，所以我的意思是，这显然看起来非常……是的，所以他们……好吧，但那不是那个问题，所以他也许必须被判无罪，因为没有证据，或者因为人们一直在，你知道，
beyond reasonable doubt test but looking at all the evidence available and then then and now was thorpe probably guilty or innocent what do you think well i think the jury had to acquit because the one okay well that's not the question that's not the question no i'll just say one thing though they the the the witnesses the key prosecution witnesses it turned out that they would they under their deals with the newspapers they were due to get more money if the thought went down so i mean that obviously looks very yeah so they were due to get more money if Thorpe went down so I mean that obviously looks very yeah so they were okay but but that's not quite quite the the question so he maybe he had to be a critic because there wasn't the evidence or because people have been you know
篡改证人什么的，但你认为索普确实资助了一次杀害诺曼·斯科特的企图吗？是的，我确实认为他可能并没有真正当真。但我告诉你什么是确凿的证据，汤姆，我们根本没提到，这是我抛出一个最爱事实的机会。索普，事实是他得到了钱。所以他得到了钱，他筹集了钱，从一个叫杰克·海伍德爵士的人那里，
tampering with the witnesses or whatever but do you think that Thorpe did sponsor an attempt to kill Norman Scott yes I do I think think he might not have really meant it. But I'll tell you what's the damning thing, Tom, which we haven't mentioned at all, and this is a chance for me to drop a favourite fact in. Thorpe, it's the fact that he gets the money. So he gets the money, he raises the money, from a man called Sir Jack Haywood,
他是一位居住在巴哈马的英国百万富翁，但也是自由党的捐赠者。他是伍尔西的主席吗？从一个叫杰克·海伍德爵士的人那里，他是一位居住在巴哈马的英国百万富翁，但也是自由党的捐赠者。现在，一些听众……他是……的主席。他在90年代成为了狼队足球俱乐部的主人。所以杰克·海伍德基本上没问任何问题就给了他这笔钱。索普没有把它交给自由党基金。他把它放在了一个单独的账户里。
who's a British millionaire who's based in the Bahamas but a donor to the Liberal Party. Who's the chairman of Woolsey? from a man called Sir Jack Haywood, who's a British millionaire who's based in the Bahamas, but a donor to the Liberal Party. Now, some listeners... Who's the chairman of... He becomes the owner of Wolverhampton Wanderers in the 1990s. So Jack Haywood gives him this money, basically no questions asked. Thorpe doesn't give it to the Liberal Party funds. He keeps it in a separate account.
正如这些案件中经常发生的那样，你追踪钱的去向。他需要那笔钱的原因是因为那笔钱是给杀手安德鲁·牛顿的。我认为那是真正可疑的事情。那是确凿的证据。是的，完全正确。而且我认为实际上，汤姆，
And as often in these cases, you follow the money. The reason he needs that money is because that money is destined for Andrew Newton, the hitman. And I think that's the really dodgy thing. That's the smoking gun. Yeah, exactly. And I think actually, Tom,
你知道，你可以理解为什么索普，我的意思是，你可以认为索普感到被困住了。他的过去有这段关系，他觉得他永远无法摆脱那种因性取向而被曝光的恐惧，是的，他觉得他必须做点什么，无论他最初是开玩笑说的还是他真的当真了，我，我，我想当它在这么多层面上发生时，它可能对他来说从来没有真正显得真实，“哦，除掉他”，我，我当时11岁，我想，是的，我11岁，我对正在发生的事情有一种模糊的感觉，我不完全确定杰里米·索普到底应该做了什么，但我有点模糊地
you know, you can understand why Thorpe, I mean, you can think Thorpe feels trapped. He's got this liaison in his past that he feels he can never rid himself of that fear of being exposed for his sexuality yeah and he feels he has to do something and whether he said it first as a joke or whether he really meant it i i think when it's happening at so many removes it probably never really seemed real to him oh just get rid of him i i was 11 i think uh yeah i was 11 and i had a vague sense of what was going on and i wasn't entirely sure what jeremy thorpe exactly was supposed to have done but i kind of vaguely
知道那是一件坏事，我们有，嗯，这里有一个来自托尼·麦高文的评论，开场击球手，作者，比我大一点，我应该说，我希望你会提到丑闻发生后在每所学校流传的糟糕笑话，例如，当杰里米·索普发现诺曼·斯科特偷渡在他的游艇上时发生了什么？他让他工作来抵消船费，所以，所以有审判蛋糕，这种东西为那样的校园笑话提供了素材，而且有一种，你知道，英国淫秽、影射、反同性恋笑话的传统，我的意思是，这，它确实推动了那个特定的磨坊，然后有一个非常有趣的，非常有趣的评论来自帕特·罗伯茨，我第一次听到“同性恋”这个词是关于索普的，我大约九岁，关于
knew that it was it was something bad and we have um a comment here from uh tony mcgowan um opening batsman and the authors um a little bit older than me i should say i hope you'll be mentioning the terrible jokes that went around every school in the wake of the scandal e.g what happened when jeremy thorpe found norman scott stowing away on his yacht he made him work his passage so so there was there was the trial cake kind of provided grist for schoolboy jokes like that and there was a kind of you know the tradition of british smut of innuendo of anti-gay jokes i mean this yeah it kind of powered that particular mill and then there's a very interesting very interesting comment from pat roberts i first heard the word homosexual with regard to thorpe i was about nine the word bimbo with regard to
加里·哈特的“荡妇”这个词，以及关于比尔·克林顿的一个我不会提到的性行为，政治丑闻是否给了受人尊敬的媒体谈论肮脏事物的许可？所以它基本上给了学童和媒体处理那种淫秽主题的许可，否则也许在70年代末，人们在谈论这些时比现在更克制，我认为一个很好的例子就是现在已经倒闭的《世界新闻报》的存在，它在50年代、60年代、70年代，你知道，在周末，在周日，《世界新闻报》总是报道关于风流牧师或者，你知道，被抓到妥协情况的人的故事，你是对的，它有一种窥淫癖，但这总是讲述那种挑逗性故事和关于
gary hart and about a sexual practice i won't mention with regard to bill clinton do political scandals give permission to the respectable media to talk dirty so it basically gives permission to school children and to the media to deal in kind of smutty subjects that otherwise perhaps back in the late 70s people were more restrained in talking about than perhaps would be now I think the good example of that is the very existence of the news of the world newspaper now defunct which in the sort of 50s 60s 70s you know at the weekend on Sundays the news of the world newspaper now defunct which in the sort of 50s 60s 70s you know um at the weekend on sundays the news of the world always had stories about philandering vicars or you know people caught in compromising situations and you're right it's kind of purience to it but it was always an excuse to tell sort of titillating stories and stories
不法行为故事的借口，我认为索普丑闻是这方面的完美例子。但我也认为它之所以真正重要，是因为在1970年代，英国政治中有一种衰败感，一种建制派的肮脏感。这很精确。我的意思是，大赢家是玛格丽特·撒切尔。你知道，无可挑剔的私生活，一个女人，投射出……这和60年代初的普罗富莫丑闻是一回事，是的，完全正确，结束了麦克米伦
about wrongdoing and i think thought the thorpe scandal was the consummate example of that. But also, I think why it really matters is because in the 1970s, there was a sense of decrepitude in British politics, a sense of establishment seediness. And this was precise. I mean, the big winner was Margaret Thatcher. You know, unimpeachable private life, a woman, sort of projected it's the same thing as with the profumo scandal in the the early 60s yeah exactly put paid to the macmillan
政府，给了它一种破旧和衰败的光环，完全正确，索普是一位共识政治家，他是那种战后稍微社会民主共识的政治家，而那正是玛格丽特·撒切尔在1979年，他受审的那一年，她所说她想要粉碎的东西，这非常能说明问题，你知道，保守党在1974年输了，因为他们太多的选民，大约两百万选民倒戈投向了自由党，那些选民在索普审判的那一年回到了玛格丽特·撒切尔身边，他们给了她所需的动力去改变1980年代的一切，我的意思是，我想休·格兰特对杰里米·索普的刻画有力地传达了魅力、机智和那种
government gave it the kind of aura of shabbiness and decrepitude exactly and thorpe is a consensus politician he's a politician of that post-war sort of slightly social democratic consensus and that's what margaret thatcher in 1979 the year that he's tried that's what she says she wants to smash and it's very telling you know the tourists had lost in 1974 because so many of their voters something like two million of their voters are defected to the liberals those voters return in the year of the thought trial to margaret Thatcher and they give her the the impetus that she needs to go and sort of change everything in the 1980s I mean I thought what what Hugh Grant's portrayal of of Jeremy Thorpe powerfully conveyed was the charm and the wit and the the kind of
风度翩翩的品质，而且，嗯，伊恩·琼斯提供了一份罗宾·戴（70年代和80年代伟大的审问者）采访索普的文字记录，关于他在1979年大选中失去北德文选区。罗宾·戴：索普先生，你认为你因共谋谋杀而被起诉是你失败的一个因素吗？索普回答说：这么说吧，罗宾，我不认为这有帮助。是的。好吧，索普真的很有趣。我的意思是，索普会做一件事，我显然是一个非常有魅力的人，会做一件事
debonair qualities and there's um Ian Jones has given a transcript of an interview between Robin Day, the great inquisitor of the 70s and 80s, interviewing Thorpe on losing his North Devon seat at the 1979 general election. Robin Day, Mr. Thorpe, do you think your prosecution for conspiracy to murder was a factor in your defeat? To which Thorpe replies, put it like this, Robin, I don't think it helped. Yeah. Well, Thorpe was really funny. I mean, Thorpe would do a thing. I'm obviously a very charismatic man would do a thing
你在政治小组节目中从未见过，所以他会出现在小组节目中，然后他会模仿其他人，我们没有足够的政治家这样做，不，政治家模仿得不够，好吧，所以，嗯，我的意思是，我认为这基本上涵盖了它，因为它并没有真正产生持久的影响，持久的冲击。我的意思是，这是一个有趣的里程碑。正如你所说，它标志着英国政治一个特定时期的结束和新时期的开始。正如我们所说，它也是对同性恋态度演变的一个有趣的里程碑。当然，它是英国历史上最著名的暗杀狗事件。
that you never see on political panel shows so he would appear on a panel show and and then he would impersonate the other the other people we don't have enough politicians doing that no politicians don't do enough impersonations okay so um i mean i think that that basically covers it because it didn't really have an enduring influence, an enduring impact. I mean, it's a kind of interesting waymark. As you say, it kind of signals the end of a particular period in British politics and the beginning of a new one. It's also, as we said, an interesting waymark in the kind of evolution of attitudes to homosexuality. And of course, it's the most famous assassination of a dog in British history.
我们有很多关于狗的问题，汤姆。我们确实有。既然这是伊恩·基利的建议，我们应该，是的，保罗·基利，抱歉。
We had a lot of questions about dogs, Tom. We did. And since this was Ian Keighley's idea that we do, I think we should, yeah, Paul Keighley, sorry.
我认为我们应该以他问的一个问题结束。在这个案件中，暗杀一只狗，可怜的老林克，是否在公共生活中产生过如此大的反响？我没有，我没有专门研究过狗，当我收到那个问题时，我举起双手把它抛了出来，我们收到了许多优秀的回复，所以我们收到了一个来自，嗯，邓利克·邓林·特明克的回复，他提到了盖勒特，这是一个关于，嗯，盖勒特是威尔士卢埃林大帝的猎犬，他回来发现他孩子的摇篮被翻倒了。婴儿本身消失了。盖勒特，他的狗，嘴边滴着血。
I think we should end with a question that he's, he's asked. And has the assassination of a dog in this case, poor old Rinker ever had such reverberations in public life? I haven't, I haven't made a special study of dogs when i got that question i threw my hands up and put it out and we've had a number of of excellent replies so we've had one from um dunlick dunlin temink who suggests gellert and that's a great story of um gellert was theound of Llewellyn the Great in Wales who came back to find his child's cradle had been turned over. The baby itself had vanished. And there was Gellert, his dog, with blood kind of dripping from its chops.
所以卢埃林认为盖勒特杀死了婴儿。他杀死了猎犬。猎犬发出了一种忠诚、信任的哀鸣，然后倒下了，卢埃林走到隔壁，发现婴儿安然无恙，还有一只盖勒特杀死的死狼，哇，那是个好故事，那是个伟大的故事，嗯，那是个好故事，然后克里斯·海因德，林肯的狗，林肯的狗叫菲多，它在林肯遇刺后幸存了下来。然后他在林肯葬礼后不久被一个醉汉暗杀。暗杀？你能暗杀吗？是的，当然。
And so Llewellyn assumes that Gellert has has killed the baby. He kills the hound. The hound gives a kind of faithful, trusting yowl and then keels over and well and goes next door and finds the baby well and alive and a dead wolf that gellert has killed wow that's a good story that's a great story um it's a good story then chris hind lincoln's dog lincoln's dog was called fido it survived the assassination of lincoln. And then he got assassinated by a drunk shortly after Lincoln's funeral. Assassinated? Could you assassinate? Yes, of course.
如果是林肯的狗，你可以暗杀。是的。戴夫·沃尔特斯，这个故事，我想实际上，我们之前提到过，流浪狗确实引发了一场战争。流浪狗战争是1925年的一场希腊-保加利亚危机，导致希腊在边境城镇佩特里奇附近短暂入侵保加利亚，起因是保加利亚士兵杀害了一名追赶狗的希腊上尉和一名哨兵。
If it's Lincoln's dog, you can assassinate. Yes. Dave Walters, the story, I think actually, which we've touched on before, stray dog did cause a war. The war of the stray dog was a Greek-Bulgarian crisis in 1925, which resulted in a brief invasion of Bulgaria by Greece near the border town of Petric after the killing of a Greek captain, chasing the dog, and a sentry by Bulgarian soldiers.
然后我们有保罗·杜布斯。理查德·夏普尔斯爵士于1973年在百慕大被暗杀，连同他的副官休·塞耶斯和他的狗，霍瑟。所以有一些著名的狗。我想我们应该结束了。我不知道死狗，但我知道一只重要的丢失的狗。
And then we have Paul Dubbs. Sir Richard Sharples was assassinated in 1973 in Bermuda, along with his ADC, Hugh Sayers, and his dog, Horser. So there are some famous dogs. I think we should end. I don't know about dead dogs, but I know about a lost dog that was important.
这既是对之前播客的致意，也是对未来播客的期待。所以已故的阿道夫·希特勒在第一次世界大战的战壕里时有一只狗。他和那只狗比和他排里的任何家伙都更亲近。他变得和这只狗非常亲密。最终他们被告知沿线移动。
It's both a nod back to a previous podcast and anticipating a future podcast. So the late Adolf Hitler had a dog when he was in the trenches in the First World War. And he was friendlier with the dog than with any of the fellas in his sort of platoon or whatever. And he became very close to this dog. And eventually they were told to move down the line.
那只狗去散步还是什么的，希特勒找不到它。他们移动了，他再也没见过那只狗。他的战友们说他们从未见过他像失去那只狗后那样心烦意乱。现在，我之所以说这是对未来播客的致意，是因为当我写我的儿童版第二次世界大战史时，在第一章我介绍了希特勒作为一个角色，我写了关于希特勒和狗的事情，我写得非常
And the dog had gone off for a walk or something and Hitler couldn't find it. And they moved down and he never saw the dog again. And his comrades said they never saw him as upset as he was after the loss of that dog. Now, the reason I say it's a nod to a future podcast is when I was writing my children's history of the Second World War, in the first chapter I introduced Hitler as a character and I had this stuff about Hitler and the dog and I'd written it in a very
催人泪下，在这一点上我还没有，我不认为我说过希特勒会成为坏人什么的，我儿子读了它，当他看到关于狗的事情时，我的意思是，他不关心第一次世界大战中所有这些人的死亡，但当他读到狗失踪时，你知道，他的嘴唇颤抖了，然后他对我说，那个有狗的人是希特勒吗？
tear-jerking way and at this point I hadn't, I don't think I'd said that Hitler was going to be the baddie or something and my son read it and when he saw the stuff about the dog, I mean he didn't care about the deaths of all these people in the First World War but when he read about the dog going missing you know, his sort of lip quivered and then he said to me, is's the person with the dog, Hitler.
我说，是的，是他。他说，哦，好吧，你不能有那只狗，因为任何读这本书的孩子都会认为那只丢失的狗一定是英雄。所以我不得不把狗拿掉。我不得不删掉它。我不得不完全删掉它，因为没有反派会在儿童书中
And I said, yeah, it is. And he said, oh, well, you can't have the dog because any child reading this book will think that the lost dog, that must be the hero. And so I had to take the dog out. I had to cut it. I had to cut it completely because no villain would ever have a dog
拥有一只狗。这很有趣。我的意思是，所以，所以我们，我们将要，嗯，下周录制一集，嗯，关于儿童历史。嗯，我想，你知道，我们一直在谈论狗。我们一直在谈论儿童历史。嗯，我们也一直在谈论我们听众的贡献。我想以我们大宪章那一集激发的一段精彩对话来结束。所以我们收到了丹诺对此的一些批评。
in a children's book. It's interesting. I mean, so, so we, we're going to be, um, uh, recording an episode next week, uh, on children's history. Um, and I think, you know, we've, we've been talking about dogs. We've been talking about children's history. Um, and we've also been talking about the contribution of our listeners. And I'd like to just fade out by a wonderful conversation that our Magna Carta episode inspired. So we had some criticism from Dano about that.
听完《历史余韵》的大宪章那一集后有点咆哮。随意反驳我。我不会为约翰辩护。他是个坏国王，听起来，是个坏人。但是，所以丹诺继续他的帖子。是的。但我们随后收到了来自Goalie X的评论，
A bit of a rant after listening to the Magna Carta episode of The Rest of History the other day. Feel free to argue with me. I will not defend John. He was a bad king, and by the sound of it, a bad person. But, and so Dano goes on with his thread. Yeah. But we then have a comment from Goalie X,
他说，他的首席顾问是一条蛇，这怎么样？对此丹诺，你知道，给丹诺巨大的赞誉，他说，好吧，我承认那看起来很糟糕，是的，我认为这就是我们听众的衡量标准，他们可以不同意，但他们友好地这样做，是的，如果你不相信约翰王的顾问是一条蛇，就去谷歌一下，是的，绝对，所以我认为在那一点上，嗯，多米尼克，谢谢你的杰作，嗯，对杰里米·索普丑闻的精彩阐述，谢谢保罗·基利提出这个建议，我希望我们那些从未听说过杰里米·索普丑闻的听众会觉得做这一集是非常值得的，所以我们很快会再和你谈，非常感谢收听，再见，再见。
who says, what about the fact that his chief advisor was a snake to which dano you know huge credit to dano he says okay that i will grant you is a bad look yeah and i think that that's that's the measure of our of the people who are listening to us is that they can disagree but they do it amicably yeah if you don't believe king john's advisor was a snake just google it yeah absolutely so i think on that note um dominic thank you for a tour de force uh a brilliant explication of um the jeremy thorpe scandal thank you to paul paul keely for suggesting after coming up with it and i hope that our um those listeners who'd never heard of the jeremy thorpe scandal will feel that it was well worth doing an episode on so we will speak to you soon thanks very much for listening bye-bye bye-bye
感谢收听《历史余韵》剧集，抢先体验、无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在restishistorypod.com注册。那是restishistorypod.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
thanks for listening to the rest is history episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《历史的余味》节目，如需抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。